amis téléspectateurs bonjour soyez les
bienvenus vous regardez et maintenant
l'émission qui revient toujours avec
plaisir et toujours avec vous sur
l'actualité politique de la semaine vous
connaissez le principe hashtag et
maintenant si vous souhaitez réagir
aujourd'hui sur ce plateau nous avons la
crème de la crème on les appelle les
spécialistes ils ont les informations et
le recul ils sont très intelligents je
vous présente mes invités Michel pruzol
bonjour ça va
avec une présentation de ce niveau
de générations vous êtes l'auteur du
livre la pauvreté une fatalité s'est
publiée aux éditions Bonneton Astrid
devilène bonjour vous êtes chef du
service politique du hatington post
votre dernier livre est paru chez dates
il s'intitule les sept péchés capitaux
de la gauche Emmanuel Voguet fait son
retour bonjour ça va Emmanuel vous êtes
communicant président de narrative vous
avez écrit politicard abécédaire des
secrets de la communication politique
c'est aux éditions de l'Atelier de
l'archer et Eugénie Bastié grand
reporter au service débat et opinion du
Figaro bonjour je signale votre livre La
guerre des idées enquêtes au coeur de
l'itinigancia française c'est à
retrouver chez Robert Lafont dans cette
émission on se demandera s'il faut
légaliser le cannabis on reviendra sur
le rapatriement des femmes et des
enfants de djihadistes en France sur le
soutien
occidental à l'armée ukrainienne qui est
en train de passer un cap et puis et
puis on se demandera si nous sommes
toujours aussi sexistes nous les
français c'est en tout cas la conclusion
d'un rapport publié cette semaine mais
d'abord merci président Larcher chaud
devant les semaines qui viennent
s'annoncent électrique sur le front
social et politique mardi prochain aura
lieu la deuxième journée de mobilisation
nationale contre la réforme des
retraites et pour l'instant pour
l'instant tout le monde campe sur ses
positions
les mesures d'âge que nous prenons sont
celles qui permettent de ramener le
système à l'équilibre en 2030 et c'est
un point sur lequel nous savons qu'il y
a un désaccord avec les organisations
syndicales mais revenir sur ce point
serait renoncer au retour à l'équilibre
et donc manquer de responsabilité pour
les générations futures nous l'avons dit
depuis le début si le gouvernement et
c'est quand même le cas ne mesure pas le
mécontentement et le nombre de personnes
qui étaient en manifestation 19 et en
grève il y a un petit problème et donc
il va falloir faire entendre un peu plus
fort les motivations de ces grèves et se
faire entendre plus fort c'est des
grèves et si les salariés le vote des
grèves reconductibles Michel on assiste
à un durcissement des positions
durcissement je sais pas je crois que du
côté en tout cas de l'opposition à cette
cette réforme
la situation n'a pas bougé d'un pouce et
je vois pas beaucoup bien comment elle
pourrait bouger puisque un la
communication du gouvernement est déjà
très floue puisqu'on a eu plusieurs
plusieurs discours sur la nécessité de
cette réforme ça se complique puisque le
président du corps piano
par la commission des finances à
l'Assemblée lui qu'on avait pris comme
référence au fait qu'il fallait
absolument faire cette réforme a dit
exactement l'inverse c'est-à-dire en
disant il y a pas dérapage des déficits
ce n'est pas une question de de
pérennisation du système nerveux là là
on est en plein dialogue de source
disponible surtout il y a un dialogue un
dialogue de méthode puisque on a d'un
côté un gouvernement qui fait une
réforme pour sans doute d'autres raisons
que c'est les retraites et ceux qui sont
maintenant c'est inacceptable et on est
pas donc c'est compliqué Eugénie
dialogue de sourd ce qui est très
compliqué c'est c'est que le fond de
cette réforme la raison principale de
cette réforme qui est l'équilibre
budgétaire est aujourd'hui une raison de
plus en plus difficile à faire
comprendre et accepter aux Français
notamment après 3 ans de covid et de
quoi qu'il en coûte ou l'état fait un
chèque par jour et on a l'impression
qu'effectivement le milliards sont
disponibles quand vous voyez qu'on a
dépensé par exemple 17 milliards pour
les tests covid pendant la période du
covid et qu'on nous dit que la réforme
des retraites par rapport à rapporter 13
milliards c'est très difficile à
entendre de dire bah écoutez on fait une
réforme difficile pour de l'argent qui
apparemment est disponible en quantité
limitée donc je trouve qu'il y a un vrai
problème non pas de c'est même pas de la
pédagogie c'est un drapeau public et je
et ça c'est quelque chose qui est
profondément maintenant enraciné dans
dans la tête des Français l'équilibre
budgétaire ce n'est plus une valeur des
politiques publiques et ça c'est très
très compliqué
on va voir cette ce dernier sondage est
là publié cette semaine à dynamique de
ses sondages qui n'est vraiment pas
bonne pour pour le gouvernement les
Français sont de plus en plus nombreux à
rejeter cette réforme ils sont 72% à
dire non c'est 6 points de plus en une
semaine de manière générale c'est ce que
vous disiez c'est une réforme injuste
pour les français pour trois quarts des
Français oui 95 il y avait une
gouvernement avait cédé il est français
il y avait des sondages donnés enfin il
était majoritairement pour cette réforme
des sondages à 51 % on va bien le ça va
jouer le gouvernement clairement inscrit
en train de perdre la bataille de
l'opinion oui et le pire c'est qu'il le
reconnaisse j'entendais un conseiller
ministériel cité par BFM TV hier dire on
a perdu la bataille de l'opinion c'est
pas comme ça qu'on s'engage dans une
bataille on dirait que même eux ils n'y
croient plus vraiment en fait c'est ça
alors que ça n'a pas commencé vraiment
une manif bah c'est à dire que je
rejoins un petit peu ce qui vient de
dire que c'est mal ficelé depuis le
démarrage on a toujours pas compris
maintenant on a on a bien compris que
c'était l'équilibre budgétaire qui a été
attendu mais enfin au départ après ça a
été on a changé de pied Emmanuel Macron
nous explique pas du tout que c'était
pour le système des retraites il y a
même des frondeurs au sein de la
majorité ce qui est très rare qui nous
disent sur sur les plateaux de télé à
visage de découvert je ne la voterai pas
en l'état donc ça se fissure un petit
peu de part et d'autre et en effet on
sent un exécutif qui n'est pas du tout à
l'offensive comme si lui-même doutait en
fait de ce du bien fondé de cette
réforme le dialogue il est impossible
aujourd'hui il y a cette réforme elle
est morte née j'ai eu l'occasion déjà de
le dire sur votre plateau pour deux
raisons fondamentales vous avez même dit
que cette réforme de retraite ne se fera
pas ressortira un jour les archives mais
vous verrez que moi je suis persuadé
qu'elle se fera pas pour une raison
simple c'est que j'ai vécu d'asser près
les 95 auquel vous faisiez référence on
ne gagne jamais contre l'opinion jamais
et en 95 effectivement on était parti
avec un discours du prêt du Premier
ministre de politique générale et de la
réforme des retraites qui avait été très
bien accueilli y compris sur les bancs
de la gauche avant que tout ça ne
dégénère là on est déjà on n'a pas
entamé la deuxième journée de
mobilisation qu'on est déjà à 72% de
c'est terrible et c'est du jamais vu et
ça vient d'un problème qui me semble lui
en revanche très politique c'est que une
réforme elle naît de quoi elle naît d'un
président qui ne fait que trois semaines
de campagne présidentielle et qui pour
tout projet à la réforme des retraites
persuadée qui va avoir une majorité à
l'assemblée qui va lui tomber comme ça
une majorité pléthorique que les
Français ne lui ont pas donné et il
maintient son projet à un moment où
s'accumule tous les problèmes vis-à-vis
des Français dans une réforme dont on
non mais dans une réforme oui mais là il
a pas de majorité c'était son seul
projet et et c'est la première fois en
revanche que on critique on s'interroge
même sur l'intérêt de la faire 95 on
s'intéressait sur comment la faire tout
le monde était d'accord pour dire il
faut faire quelque chose mais comment on
le fait là c'est la légitimité même qui
est mise en cause et d'ailleurs les
Français s'y trompent pas ils sont
aujourd'hui 72% à 10 euros
des retraites a déjà été populaire
est très délicate c'est qu'il y a quand
même un deuxième gros sujet qui
préoccupe plus les Français que les
retraites le pouvoir d'achat et c'est ça
qui est vraiment la préoccupation des
politiques disent sur les marchés on ne
parle pas des retraites on parle du
pouvoir d'achat et donc il y a l'Élysée
Paris aussi sur cette idée que
finalement les Français sont préoccupés
par d'autres choses que des retraites
des retraites c'est loin c'est c'est
c'est
il y a une opposition résignation il
parie sur ça je sais pas s'ils ont
raison c'est vrai que le courant d'achat
il a plus rien sauf qu'il y a beaucoup
de monde dans la rue entre 1 et 2
millions on pensait pas que ce serait
autant et moi j'ajoute des petits que je
vois oui mais c'était il y a longtemps
enfin je veux dire moi je trouve qu'il y
a des signaux par exemple il y a
beaucoup de gens qui n'ont jamais
manifesté qui s'y rendent il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ne manifestent pas
et qui soutiennent et il y a surtout moi
je l'ai vu j'habite à Pantin et je
travaille à Paris et dans les deux cas
j'ai vu des gens tractés ce qui est très
rare hors période électorale non à la
réforme des retraites des jeunes le
sourire etc ça c'est des choses moi j'ai
pas vu dans la période récente d'un
engagement politique comme ça
spontanément
entre 2010 si je peux me
la mobilisation était progressive
c'est-à-dire que c'est monté en
puissance pour arriver effectivement à
un million et toi
une chose sur le sur le sur le côté
difficile budgétaire c'est que le corps
encore une fois explique le besoin de
faire pour les 3 années pour les trois
années qui viennent et de 5 milliards
par an 5 milliards pas plus sur 340
milliards par contre 2030 oui pendant 10
ans déficitaire aujourd'hui
mais il y a logique c'est pas la même
situation d'équilibre il y a d'autres
solutions je vous dis l'égalité fameux
on va parler du sexisme tout à l'heure
vous réglez ce problème là c'est 6
milliards qui tombent directement
l'emploi du seigneurs ça règle les
arènes le problème de des retraites donc
il n'y a pas de problème fondamental ni
à 2030
démographique 1,7 actif pour pour un
retraité ça n'est pas tenable alors moi
je suis moi je suis pas le droit de
sortir du système par répartition si
vous voulez capitalisation on va pas
les amis les amis j'aimerais vous faire
entendre Laurent Berger Laurent Berger
secrétaire général de la CFDT il était
devant l'Assemblée nationale ce mercredi
avec les 7 autres principaux syndicaux
il est revenu sur la dynamique de cette
mobilisation écoutez-le vous savez on a
réussi une excellente mobilisation le 19
qui était quasi inédite depuis
maintenant de nombreuses années ça
suffit à pouvoir se faire entendre c'est
ce qu'on veut expliquer au gouvernement
on n'a pas on n'a pas besoin le
durcissement à tout crin c'est c'est
partir c'est perdre une partie de
l'opinion donc nous on veut durcir sur
les propositions on veut dire cire sur
le en montrant que c'est largement suivi
par les salariés de ce pays et donc
c'est ça qui est aujourd'hui en jeu
c'est de réussir le 31 janvier l'avenir
de la mobilisation dépend de cet homme
Astrid c'est souvent le le pivot en fait
Laurent Berger en général surtout pour
un gouvernement de centriste comme celui
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est bien d'avoir
avec soi la CFDT là le fait d'avoir les
8 organisations groupées Unis c'est très
rare et ça évidemment que ça renforce le
la contestation et les opposants à cette
réforme on va parler de ce qui va se
passer au Parlement parce que le texte
va effectivement être discuté par les
députés les vacances scolaires elle
débute le 4 février 2 jours plus tard le
6 l'Assemblée nationale débutera
l'examen dans l'hémicycle de cette
réforme une réforme qui fait débat vous
en parler tout à l'heure au sein même de
la majorité écoutez
il faut faire ce qu'on croit juste et il
faut arrêter aussi de faire des
marqueurs politiques et surtout pardon
arrêtez de dire que sur les plateaux ici
ou ailleurs on doit faire preuve de
pédagogie la pédagogie c'est quoi c'est
nous on sait et vous les Français vous
êtes des cons on va vous expliquer
pourquoi vous avez tort trail
parlementaire c'est pas juste de dire
oui ou non c'est d'essayer d'améliorer
un texte en l'occurrence nous avons avec
mes amis en commun c'est pas mal de
proposition et on va voir comment on
peut les faire évoluer pour rendre ce
texte votable je souhaite évidemment
mais en l'état c'est non en l'état j'ai
jamais dit que c'était non j'ai dit en
l'état je peux pas voter oui
vous connaissez un peu les frondeurs
vous avez participé à quelques
coalitions quelques gouvernements enfin
pas quelques quelques
parties de ceux qui ont voté contre le
traité européen dès d'entrée de
quinquennat c'est aujourd'hui pour le
gouvernement c'est fondament ils sont
très 7 8 c'est ça la grande différence
sur les deux idées de frondeurs si on
met sur le petit du même mot c'est que
nous étions structurés autour de d'idées
fortes qui étaient qui n'arrivaient pas
sur le sur un débat particulier donc
surtout plus nombreux et on était plus
nombreux dès le départ d'une trentaine
et vraiment je vous dis la structuration
était on avait un ministre et cetera
enfin bref des figures titulaires comme
Henry Emmanuel livre c'était quand même
une autre idée là on voit bien que ce
sont plus des des des rapports
individuels mais mais qui disent quelque
chose qui de toute façon quelque chose
qu'on savait de cette majorité qui est
une majorité qui n'est pas homogène qui
est faite de d'horizon très différents
et on le voit bien quand on est sur un
sujet très dur notamment vis-à-vis des
Français
c'est plus compliqué
il y a deux grandes différences quand
même c'est que l'époque des frondeurs il
y avait une majorité absolue bien sûr
oui et donc il y avait pas un risque
aujourd'hui chaque fois compte
aujourd'hui chaque fois c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
que moi j'appelle pas ça des frondeurs
vous avez la première Premier ministre
qui est rentré dans l'histoire en
appelant à enrichir le texte donc on
appelle aux gens à s'exprimer quand il
s'exprime si ça va pas on dit ah mais
non mais finalement faudrait peut-être
que vous repliez les Gaules et que vous
rentriez vos idées dans vos poches et
dire que tout est mal ficelé elle va
finir par faire passer à l'injupé pour
le roi de la réforme de la retraite
continue comme ça franchement j'aimerais
aussi qu'on parle des LR parce que donc
effectivement chaque fois compte on voit
que ça coince aussi un peu chez les
républicains eugénique est-ce que vous
pensez de la position aujourd'hui des
républicains on sait qu'avec ce qui
avait dit lait en quelque sorte avec les
habits de borne aujourd'hui on voit que
c'est plus tout à fait évident si vous
avez arrivé à résumé la position de la
républicain
allez aussi ambigu que celle d'Emmanuel
Macron sur la guerre en Ukraine enfin il
y a les côtés on ne sait pas exactement
de ce ce qu'ils veulent et en fait moi
j'entendais le jour j'entendais un
député LR à la radio qui qui parlait et
j'avais l'impression d'entendre un
débuter la France insoumise c'est à dire
qu'il disait c'est très fort mais très
dur elle est brutale nous allons la
modérer nous allons infliger le
gouvernement enfin on a l'impression que
eux qui réclamaient la retraite 65 ans
c'était dans le l'ADN l'ADN
programmatique de l'alerte pas grand
chose mais il y avait ça promet de
François Fillon province aujourd'hui on
a des députés députés LR qui moderne le
gouvernement sur la réforme donc c'est
totalement illisible ça s'explique en
effet par une chose qui en fait
électorale c'est à dire que les derniers
députés à l'air qui restent sont plutôt
dans des territoires ruraux ils sont
plus dans les grandes métropoles CSP+
qui soutiennent et qui sont partis chez
Macron qui soutiennent la réforme des
retraites certes mais ça peut-être ça
s'explique par des raisons électorales
mais ça ne ça ça trahit quand même
l'absence de colonne vertébrale
l'idéologie je résume ce que je n'y
viens de dire les LR se sont gauchisés
c'est ça il y a toujours eu une droite
sociale ça je crois que c'est ça fait
aussi partie de l'ADN d'une femme de LR
mais ce qui est dans le programme de dix
dernières années c'est ça et surtout le
Congrès qui vient de se dérouler il y a
quand même Éric Chiotti qui a dit à tout
le monde je vote je voterai la réforme
d'Emmanuel Macron et d'Elizabeth borne
sur 65 ans qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ce
qui se passe c'est que en effet c'est un
parti qui va très mal qui moi je suis
très étonné du temps qu'on lui accorde
encore c'est vrai qu'à l'Assemblée il a
un rôle important
mais c'est un parti qui
entrain un petit peu de s'effondrer
comme le Parti socialiste donc il y a à
l'intérieur des gens qui pensent sur toi
eux des gens qui en effet sont
représentatifs d'un territoire où c'est
des catégories populaires rurales et qui
ont pas du tout envie de cette réforme
donc ils écoutent aussi le terrain ils
ont ils savent faire de la politique
mais ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il y a un
problème de cohérence en fait à
l'intérieur c'est-à-dire que mais la
campagne de Valérie Pécresse nous l'a
montré c'est à dire que c'est une
centriste qui a fait une campagne à la
droite la plus au confins de l'extrême
droite et ça c'est plus possible ce
grand écart idéologique là et c'est ce
qui se passe là à l'Assemblée ensuite on
verra comment ça se ça se il y a un
problème de marque c'est que le
changement majoritaire important c'est
que avant il suffisait d'avoir le logo
RPR BNP LR pour être élu et aujourd'hui
c'est un handicap donc donc la marque ne
porte plus elle est vécue comme un
handicap et donc chacun essaye de sauver
sa peau parce que quand il en reste plus
que soit 60 et peut-être 30 ou 20 s'il
devait y avoir une dissolution dans le
meilleur bien il faut il faut
impérativement être proche de sa base et
la base qu'est ce qu'elle dit elle dit
non sommes-nous toujours aussi sexiste
nous les français c'est notre deuxième
thème cinq ans après le mouvement me
tool au conseil à l'égalité a publié
cette semaine son baromètre annuel sur
le sexisme et selon lui le phénomène ne
recule pas en France au contraire sur
certains points il aurait même tendance
à s'aggraver écoutez oui ce rapport est
alarmant il y a vraiment de quoi
réfléchir et surtout lancer une alerte
au pouvoir public pour dire maintenant
ça suffit il faut comprendre que le
sexisme dit ordinaire les petites choses
de tous les jours qui paraissent banales
conduisent malheureusement directement
au sexisme le plus violent que ce
sexisme ordinaire perdure qu'il apparaît
malheureusement encore et plus fortement
dans les générations de 25 34 ans à mon
avis dû au fait que cette génération
baignée dans les réseaux sociaux le
numérique le porno et que ce sont des
éléments de violence banalisées et de
domination masculine et qu'il faut donc
réagir ce rapport est-il un reflet
honnête de la réalité sur ce plateau
deux invités ne sont pas d'accord vous
allez le voir pas du tout d'accord et
cette fois j'exagère dès que j'exagère
pas du tout d'un côté on a Astrid de
l'autre Eugénie à Street vous allez
commencer vous avez 45 secondes oui il
se rapport est plutôt honnête
enfin moi j'avoue que je connais bien
ces questions là et j'ai pas besoin du
rapport du HCE pour savoir que le
sexisme existe dans la société moi j'ai
écrit un livre en 2018 qui n'a pas bougé
d'une ligne qui s'appelle harceler et
qui démontre qui a un continuum en fait
entre le harcèlement de rue le sexisme
les violences en général jusqu'au
féminicides ce rapport il dit il fait 10
propositions très intéressantes pour que
ça recule notamment chez les jeunes
Emmanuel Macron qui a reçu les autrices
du rapport n'a retenu qu'une seule
proposition celle qui était tout en bas
la journée nationale contre le sexisme
et honnêtement je crois qu'on va pas y
arriver on va pas faire reculer les
violences sexistes et sexuelles dans ce
pays avec une journée nationale contre
le sexisme c'est très bien mais il
manque ce que réclame les associations
c'est à dire 1 à 2 milliards d'euros par
an
c'est incroyable vous allez respecter
vos anges et c'est l'expérience bon
Eugénie vous non ce rapport ça le fait
pas quoi 45 secondes
au féminisme de le mettre tout dans le
même sac c'est à dire effectivement de
la blague sexiste devant la machine à
café au féminicide il y aura un
continuum et de et du cliché au
stéréotype à la violence sur un
continent je ne suis pas d'accord avec
ça je pense qu'il faut hiérarchiser les
violences et je pense que c'est le
problème de ce rapport c'est qu'il met
tout dans le même sac et du coup on ne
sait plus quelle est la priorité
notamment la sécurité des femmes dans
les transports par exemple ou
l'industrie pornographique qui a un
chantier énorme il aurait fallu faire un
rapport en fait juste sur l'industrie
pornographique on aurait déjà beaucoup
plus avancé là on met il y a tout et
n'importe quoi et en fait on regarde
d'autres chiffres on peut aussi se
réjouir comme par exemple le fait que
tous les clichés associés aux femmes
sont
sont minoritaire dans l'opinion par
exemple les femmes peuvent être présents
un public etc donc on peut aussi se
réjouir on regarde que ce qui va mal
merci génial on va voir les chiffres
dont vous parlez effectivement ces
chiffres mis en avant par le rapport les
violences existent encore dans des
proportions alarmantes nous dit ce
rapport 37% des Françaises interrogés
ont déjà vécu une situation de non
consentement 14% ont déjà subi un acte
sexuel imposé c'est à dire une agression
sexuelle ou un viol d'autres chiffres
avec ces stéréotypes stéréotypes qui
perdure est-ce problématique une femme
cuisine tous les jours pour sa famille
49% des femmes répondent que oui 37%
seulement chez les hommes autre chiffre
38% des femmes et 52% des hommes
considèrent qu'il est normal que l'homme
paye l'addition en premier rendez-vous
le HCE parle d'une situation
caractéristique de sexisme ordinaire
Emmanuel
c'est comme si Emmanuel Emmanuel Macron
s'est mis tout n'était jamais passé par
là quoi non c'est encore une fois moi je
suis assez d'accord avec ce que vient de
dire Eugénie c'est qu'il faut pas tout
mettre dans le même panier on est tous
personne ne peut considérer qu'il faut
pas s'attaquer à ces questions mais on
peut pas traiter tous les problèmes du
sexisme de la même manière
dans le sexisme
il y a trop de choses quand je lis dans
le rapport j'ai lu un truc
on est d'accord
d'une haute autorité rattaché à Mathilde
c'est la raison pour laquelle on dit
qu'il faut qu'il faut qu'il y ait des
catégories et qu'on s'attaque à ce qui
nous ce qu'on considère il y a des actes
plus grave c'est ce que vous voulez dans
le rapport par exemple j'aimerais qu'on
m'explique je l'ai lu
attentivement comment est-ce que ce
rapport en temps lutter contre le
sexisme en nous expliquant qu'il
faudrait interdire des jouets genre et
ça c'est une
c'est ridicule c'est ridicule c'est ça
que je veux dire donc essayons essayons
le féminisme le féminicide c'est la
priorité des priorités la question du
pornographique c'est la priorité des
priorités et tout le monde s'accordera à
dire qu'il faut le qu'il faut le traiter
il faut simplement si on veut être vous
savez c'est le rapport signal bruit en
communication voilà plus on est large et
plus la cible est difficile à atteindre
voilà donc il faut essayer à mon avis de
se concentrer sur trois quatre priorités
sur lesquelles tout le monde sera
d'accord le porno déjà sur le diagnostic
que la France les Français sont toujours
mais aussi c'est pas la question si il y
a le diagnostic et recommandations mais
est-ce que pourquoi on interroge jamais
le sexisme dans l'autre sens aussi c'est
à dire moi j'aimerais bien qu'on demande
aux femmes par exemple pensez-vous qu'un
homme sur deux ou trois est un violeur
parce qu'avait dit Caroline de Haas et
on regardera les réponses ce serait
intéressant parce que aussi des préjugés
sur les hommes qui a dit que dist un
certain né au féminisme que les hommes
sont tous des violeurs par exemple et
dans le rapport il y a un truc très
intéressant c'est que le rapport se
déplore et se lamente du fait que cet
homme sur dix considère que la phrase
tous les hommes sont sexistes
généralisent vous rendez compte ça veut
dire que si vous dites si vous n'êtes
pas d'accord avec la phrase tous les
hommes sont sexistes vous êtes sexisme
même pas c'est pour montrer qu'il y a
des billets quand même parce qu'il
existe toujours un sexisme aujourd'hui
en France et bien sûr qu'il existe des
comportements sexistes je ne dis
absolument pas simplement moi je pense
et je pense qu'ils sont que ce n'est pas
par la déconstruction systématique des
stéréotypes qu'on arrive à lutter contre
le sexisme mais compte mais par
l'éducation à certains normes de vie en
collectivité alors justement sur
l'éducation je vais vous faire réagir
Michel regardez regardez ce chiffre
toujours du même rapport parmi les
hommes de moins de 35 ans les clichés
masculinistes restent très présent 23%
23% des moins de 35 ans pense qu'il faut
être violent pour se faire respecter
Michel non mais moi je je suis pas tout
à fait d'accord avec ce qui vient d'être
dit c'est à dire que
[Musique]
l'éducation ne suffit pas en soi moi je
suis sidéré j'ai une fille de 20 ans et
en 19 ans à une de 30 ans je vois au
quotidien dans ce qu'elle me raconte
dans leur relation y compris avec des
copains en soirée etc des formes de
violence sexy que j'ai pas connu moi mon
époque c'est à dire qu'il y a il y a
aussi une tranche d'âge où les choses
sont extrêmement radicales là-dessus et
moi je reste cinq ans
je reste sur l'idée de jean-y il y a
quand même une déconstruction à faire
moi je me rappelle d'une d'une c'est un
spot publicitaire d'une marque de de
protection périodique qui montrait à des
petites filles des petits garçons qui
leur demande disait qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire courir comme une fille
et qu'est-ce que ça veut dire lancer un
objet comme une fille et déjà c'est des
enfants et des petites filles il y avait
une structuration genre incroyable les
petites filles d'intégreraient pas
encore le fait que il y avait une
différence c'est à dire elle disait quoi
comme fille c'est quoi vite et à
l'adolescence ça change donc moi je
pense que il faut vraiment qu'on
travaille sur cette intelligence aussi
avec les enfants parce que elle dit
quelque chose sur le sexisme plus tard
et moi je crois qu'il y a de je crois
vraiment qu'il y a une ligne de dérapage
là dessus c'est l'éducation est
importante mais il faut aussi qu'on
aborde la réalité de cette chose-là
très dans une société encore
effectivement très masculin sur cette
très patriarche
ils ont enfin ils ont quand même vécu
MiTo et finalement on regarde dans les
chiffres que finalement féminisme il y a
toujours ce qu'on appelle les backlash
dans la théorie féminine ça veut dire un
retour de bâtons qui est toujours dès
qu'il y a eu une progression un progrès
une avancée sur le féminisme souvent il
y a ce retour là c'est classique nous on
observe par exemple sur les réseaux
sociaux des très jeunes TikTok par
exemple on a fait une enquête récemment
sur le Foss pour montrer qu'il y a des
réseaux masculinistes misogynes très en
vogue et très suivi donc c'est aussi un
peu le retour de bâton de mitouka en
effet fait changer les choses et qui
pour moi est de l'ordre de la révolution
c'est politisé mais certaines manières
c'est que vous voulez être mais ce qui
est clair et net c'est que il faut moi
je pense qu'il faut déconstruire
absolument les les préjugés de genre à
l'école dès l'école moi dans cette
enquête dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure je l'ai vu au sport au sport
c'est très intéressant alors qu'il est
gamin ont 10 ou 12 ans vous les mettez
filles d'un côté garçon de l'autre alors
que c'est exactement les mêmes physiques
vous pourriez à 10 ans je suis désolé un
petit garçon ou une petite fille bon et
ben moi j'ai
à l'occasion de ce reportage j'ai visité
des écoles par exemple c'était le rugby
mixte et ben je peux vous dire que les
classes sont beaucoup moins sexistes et
en fait moi j'en ai un peu aussi assez
de cette de cette génération qu'on
perpétue et qui fait la petite fille
d'un côté les petits garçons d'autres
c'est un peu has been en un sens et ça
c'est la première des choses après il
faut bosser sur tout le reste évidemment
jusqu'au féministe ce qui est pas fait
par le gouvernement malgré la grande
cause mais de du quinquennat
par exemple quand on s'étonne que les
jeunes soient plus sexistes que les
vieux mais en fait ça a toujours existé
dans le sens où par exemple vous avez un
pic de testostérone entre 20 ans et 30
ans qui fait que la virilité est
beaucoup plus j'ai pas dit que c'était
naturel il fait une naturalisé il faut
évidemment mettre à distance la biologie
mais ça s'explique aussi par un par un
contexte
naturel ce qui veut pas dire qu'il faut
pas le contrer par la culture et le
mettre à distance etc et faire une
éducation mais il y a des différences
tout ce que Simone de Beauvoir a écrit
quand même génial vous mettez à battre
tout ce que
la construction la différence des sexes
c'est purement construite socialement ça
c'est certain et je pense qu'on apprend
par exemple en Suède on a interdit les
publicités pour les jouer genre on s'est
rendu compte que les garçons et les
petites filles dans leur chambre avaient
exactement le même les mêmes les mêmes
choix de jouer genre que dans tous les
autres pays européens donc ça n'a pas
marché parce que après c'est pas
automatique non mais ça ne marche pas
parce que enfin moi j'ai eu un livre
passionnant d'un primatologue
récemment qui a étudié les singes vous
donnais des jouets à des singes un des
camions et des poupées les petits c'est
mâles vont se jouer ruer sur les camions
et les petites filles sur les poupées ce
qui m'ont bien que c'est pas culturel
donc il faut aussi reprendre en question
cette dimension biologique mais bien sûr
avec une dimension éducative et là je
pense que je vous rejoindrai il faut
effectivement mais ne Gaumont pas la
différence des sexes
l'éducation sera toujours moins forte
aujourd'hui j'ai fait un truc qui va
être un peu caricatural que l'industrie
de la pornographie par exemple or
l'industrie de la pornographie a une
puissance de votre terrible donc
l'éducation donc l'éducation ne suffira
pas en soi il faut qu'on aille beaucoup
plus loin là-dessus justement Emmanuel
un autre Emmanuel avait fait de cette
cause de l'égalité homme-femme la grande
cause du quinquennat on en est où
aujourd'hui bah nulle part nulle part
facile à grande cause
si la grande cause du quinquennat
accouche d'une journée d'une journée
nationale contre le sexisme autant vous
dire que ça ou rien c'est à peu près
pareil donc donc non je je je continue à
penser quand vous parliez des 1 ou 2
milliards par an qui devrait être
dépensés qui devrait être dépenser sur
des des thématiques et des et des
combats qui doivent être ciblés encore
une fois si on veut être l'idée n'est
pas de dénoncer il faut arrêter de
dénoncer maintenant il faut être
efficace donc il faut avec nos moyens
commencer à s'attaquer sur ce qui est le
plus problématique le plus dangereux et
mettre les moyens qui vont avec pour
pouvoir lutter et c'est pas un rapport
qui lutte contre ce genre de choses pas
plus qu'une journée mondiale de je ne
sais quoi une journée nationale de je ne
sais quoi les Journées Nationales on en
a soupé voilà il y a la journée
nationale de la femme et pour autant
vous voyez le rapport il y a la journée
nationale contre la tabagie et pourtant
on va on va discuter de la légalisation
du cannabis etc donc les Journées
Nationales on sait vous savez c'est
comme quand on dit les grands machins
alors en France on a le la grande cause
le Grand Paris le grand truc le grand
alors là on va avoir une grande cause
nationale qui accouche d'une souris
[Musique]
arrêtons la posture soyons dans l'action
merci beaucoup Emmanuel autre sujet
encore une semaine éprouvante pour les
civils Ukrainiens le pays a été la cible
de nouveau bombardements massif alors
que les combats font toujours rage à
l'est du territoire mais Kiev pourra
bientôt compter dans ces combats sur des
chars de fabrication
occidentales Berlin et Washington ont
enfin donné leur feu vert cette semaine
nous allons également fournir à
l'Ukraine des chars de combat léopard 2
c'est le résultat d'une consultation
intensive une fois de plus avec nos
alliés et nos partenaires internationaux
aujourd'hui j'annonce que les États-Unis
vont envoyer 31 chars Abraham sans
Ukraine soit l'équivalent d'un bataillon
ukrainien
Emmanuel on est dans une escalade par la
force des choses aujourd'hui non on est
on est dans un objectif de guerre qui
qui est mouvant qui n'est pas défini on
est le soutien des
Occidentaux à l'Ukraine a été basée sur
un principe assez nouveau qui est il
faut que gagner la guerre sans qui est
un défait voilà c'est comme dans un
match de foot il faut gagner un match
mais il faut que l'autre équipe ne le
perde pas c'est impossible donc c'est
ce n'est pas possible
mais quand les Américains attaquent le
Japon pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale
c'est pas pour envahir le Japon donc
mettre un terme à la guerre voilà donc
là si si on veut à un moment que que
l'Ukraine puisse commencer à agir il va
falloir mais pour l'instant tout le
matériel qui est envoyé à l'Ukraine il
faut savoir et brider c'est-à-dire que
et il est effectivement [__] de manière
à ce que l'Ukraine puisse mener une
guerre défensive et pas offensive les
grandes différences entre le Japon et la
Russie c'est que la Russie à l'arme
nucléaire
un peu trop rapide mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que non mais d'accord mais la
guerre qui consiste à simplement
défendre son territoire elle est elle
est menée à l'échec parce que parce que
par définition on se replie et que on
n'a pas de moyens d'offensive la
contre-offensive dans dans un conflit
elle est pas faite pour aller envahir
l'agresseur elle est faite pour menacer
l'agresseur de manière à ce que il ne
continue pas son offensive
[Musique]
et on est dans une situation pour le
coup je trouve avec une très grande
échelle
l'Ukraine c'est un peu aujourd'hui la
question Quels sont les lignes rouges on
va écouter Marine Le Pen pour qui bah
c'est lignes rouge sont très claires
la question c'est est-ce que tout ça ne
va pas aggraver cette guerre et quand la
guerre s'aggrave les morts se
multiplient alors est-ce que c'est
l'objectif est-ce que en réalité en
armant avec des armes lourdes est-ce
qu'on ne va pas d'abord
internationaliser le conflit qui est un
danger quand même majeur en tout cas un
risque majeur et deuxièmement est-ce que
l'on ne va pas s'éloigner d'une solution
négociée de paix sachant que aucun
conflit aujourd'hui au monde quasiment
ne se règle de manière militaire on voit
cette question elle continue de cliver
dans le spectacle
parce que c'est vrai qu'on ne voit pas
l'issue militaire de ce conflit
effectivement parce que c'est un conflit
asymétrique avec une puissance nucléaire
c'est vraiment un exemple même de
théorie des jeux
c'était très très complexe d'en sortir
sans que il y a un côté qui explose et
je et d'où la d'où la difficulté c'est à
dire que on a on arme mais jusqu'à un
certain point
qui fait que nous on va faire vraiment
basculer la guerre euh et et je trouve
que la séquence sur les chars l'envoi ou
pas de chars lourds en Ukraine était
aussi révélatrice de nos propres
faiblesses diplomatiques militaires
parce que on voit bien que la France si
elle ne peut pas envoyer ces Charles
Leclerc c'est aussi avant tout parce
qu'elle en a pas assez et que nous avons
un déficit de notre programme et donc et
je et on voit le malaise même de l'Union
européenne aussi parce que les Allemands
ont fait le choix d'envoyer leur Charlie
ou pas tout en ayant une contrepartie
des Américains et non pas des Français
donc ça montre deux choses c'est la
faiblesse notre outil militaire et la
faiblesse du couple franco-allemand
c'est qu'ils sont extrêmement complexes
à utiliser qui demande une formation
beaucoup plus grande que les autres
chats qui demandent derrière parce que
quand on envoie un char il faut envoyer
de quoi le réparer le fait d'entretenir
etc envoyer
donc c'est très compliqué pour la France
on est un peu dans un but de
polichinelle
la différence aussi
avec nous justement on a aussi l'arme
nucléaire donc on n'a pas besoin d'avoir
autant de chats mais ce qui est vrai
c'est que là on en a à peu près 130
opérationnels donc ça paraît compliqué
de nous donner
sur le sur le volet politique politique
français qu'est-ce que cette guerre on
Ukraine est en train de révéler dans la
danse dans la classe politique française
on voit effectivement Marie Le Pen qui
essaye à chaque fois de s'opposer
Emmanuel Macron qui dit bah voilà on va
aider les Ukrainiens jusqu'au bout à
gauche moi je suis assez étonné de sonar
qu'on vient d'entendre de Marine Le Pen
qui a tout fait pour faire oublier ses
relations avec la Russie et Vladimir
Poutine et qu'il a reprend une part de
la rhétorique un putin en disant
attention on va plus avoir de la paix
risquer la paix elle est déjà enfin il y
a pas de paix en fait donc c'est sûr que
la toute la rhétorique de l'escalade
beaucoup d'experts ou de diplomates
français vous direz en fait l'escalade
elle est déjà là il y a déjà des canons
européens en Ukraine il y a déjà une
escalade qui a été fomentée enfin
commencer par Vladimir Poutine donc moi
ce que je je trouve que finalement ce
qui est important c'est l'unité en fait
des alliés de l'Europe moi je vois pas
une un gap comme ça béant entre eux je
trouve que au contraire les gens se
parlent sur les sanctions ça a été
unanime alors que franchement c'est pas
du tout ce à quoi ça s’enlève la lumière
Poutine moi je trouve que l'Europe la
diplomatie des alliés en général et
quand même vu le contexte inédit et très
compliqué convenable en fait
c'est la fin d'une époque on a désarmé
l'armée française sur le dos de la
globalisation heureuse qui nous faisait
imaginer que la guerre était impossible
et je vous rappelle que au tout début du
premier mandat du Président de la
République Emmanuel Macron il a viré son
chef d'état-major des armées le général
De Villiers qui réclamait plus de moyens
pour être pour être cohérent avec un
système de défense autonome et et
indépendant aujourd'hui on se rend
compte que la guerre a haute intensité
elle est à nos portes et que ça n'est
pas un mirage et aujourd'hui
on paye alors c'est pas la faute
d'Emmanuel Macron on paye des années de
reculade ou Bercy à arbitrer contre le
ministère de la Défense et j'imagine que
le la principale problématique
aujourd'hui du ministre de la défense de
Monsieur Lecornu dans son bureau c'est
comment est-ce que je relance des lignes
de production parce que maintenant il va
falloir faire face à ce nouveau danger
autre problème étatique du gouvernement
merci Emmanuel Macron est-il dangereux
de rapatrier les femmes djihadistes les
femmes de djihadistes et les enfants de
djihadistes tous sont de nationalité
française ce qui pose un certain nombre
de questions ce mardi en tout cas le
gouvernement a confirmé que 15 femmes et
32 enfants détenus dans des camps de
prisonniers djihadistanciés avaient été
rapatriés certains élus sont inquiète
écoutez
nous apprenons par la presse que 15
femmes et 32 enfants sont revenus sans
compter des 31 femmes et les 67 enfants
l'année dernière
assumez-vous ce changement de troctrice
c'est-à-dire l'abandon du cas par cas et
ses retours massifs comment pouvez-vous
garantir la sécurité des Français face à
ces personnes qui haillissent toujours
la France vous êtes d'accord au génie il
est dangereux de rapatrier c'est
français faut rappeler qu'ils sont
français de nationalité française et des
citoyens français oui ils sont français
parce que François Hollande n'a jamais
mis enfin mis en place la déchéance de
nationalité qui voulait faire pour les
djihadistes pour les femmes aussi
djihadistes et je crois qu'effectivement
on a envie spontanément se faire une
différence entre les enfants et les
femmes il y a un devant enfin ses
enfants n'ont jamais décidé d'aller
là-bas ils sont innocents des crimes de
leurs parents ça me paraît un principe
de droit évident le problème c'est que
ce qui dit rapporterait les enfants dira
pas trier les femmes et ça ça pose un
problème en effet parce que parce que
parce que je pense qu'on parlait de
sexisme tout à l'heure je pense qu'il
est sexiste de penser que les femmes
djihadistes moins dangereuse que les
hommes djihadistes c'est aussi des
femmes dangereuses
combattantes parce que effectivement
là-bas ils sont très sexistes ne
combattent pas mais mais elles sont
aussi dangereuses elles ont elles
peuvent faire du prosélytisme et on a on
a fait un papier dans le Figaro qui
montrait le profil effectivement très
inquiétant de ces femmes donc et moi je
sur le principe pour les enfants moi je
suis je suis plutôt favorable mais
est-ce qu'on a les moyens de surveiller
les femmes qui reviennent est-ce qu'on a
les outils véritablement en place pour
en tout cas je demande davantage de
transparence parce que je pense que
c'est que c'est il faut pas du tout être
naïfs une autre alternative Michel à se
rapatriement alors pour les enfants moi
je pense qu'on a absolument pas le choix
et que c'est on aurait déjà dû le faire
depuis longtemps ce sont effectivement
des enfants français qui ne sont pas
responsables des crimes de leur parent
même si certains ont grandi dans des
conditions difficiles qui va rendre
quand même des choses il va falloir
quand même surveiller un peu ce que ces
enfants là deviennent mais on a des
sculptures en France qui permettent de
les accueillir certains ont des familles
qui seront aussi prêtes à écrire moi
j'ai rencontré beaucoup de
grands-parents de qui se désespérés
d'avoir leurs petits-enfants là-bas et
qui sont prêts à y compris à les couper
de leur relation
on peut pas en discuter sur les femmes
je pense que les choses sont sont plus
sont moins caricatural ou sur moi tout
blanc ou tout noir je pense qu'il y a du
cas par cas effectivement il y a des
femmes qui sont trop embarquées dans une
histoire qui qui leur apparu ce qu'elle
était et toutes ne sont pas au même au
même degré je dirais de dangerosité
c'est ça qu'il va falloir
qu'il va falloir analyser avec
extrêmement de précision ça veut dire
qu'il faut mettre des moyens spécifiques
effectivement autour du retour de ces
femmes ça veut dire d'accord faut savoir
d'éradicaliser est-ce que vous allez
radicaliser et puis certaines sont
passibles de la justice en France quoi
il va falloir aussi moi je préfère
qu'elle soit jugée chez nous plutôt que
dans des dans des tribunaux ou la
justice c'est pas tout à fait ce qu'elle
est vous savez les bombardements
qu'elles sont ces femmes là qu'elles
soient là-bas ou ici ce sera la même
monter devant ça on a bien compris
depuis longtemps que le les frontières
pour une bombardement elles n'existait
pas je pense tellement donc moi je
préfère qu'on les aie ici en
surveillance avec des moyens nécessaires
pour faire ça et pour les enfants
aujourd'hui ben non ce qu'on a les
moyens est-ce qu'on sait on sait on sait
faire ni l'un ni l'autre c'est ça le
problème c'est que plutôt que de
discuter de savoir si elles doivent
rentrer ou pas rentrer la question c'est
savoir si elle rentre qu'est-ce qu'on a
comme moyen pour assurer le suivi et
garantir la sécurité c'est très
compliqué parce que humainement on peut
on ne peut qu'être d'accord mais mais en
vrai et y compris même si je vais pas
être très très populaire en disant cela
mais il y a des enfants qui dès le plus
jeune âge sont armés sont éduqués dans
l'idée que que tous leurs problèmes
viennent des pays qu'ils ont quittés et
qui reviennent avec
structure mentale là il faut pas être
angélique faut en avoir faut en avoir
conscience toute proportion gardée moi
j'ai beaucoup travaillé en Colombie les
phares faisaient la même chose il
tuait les parents ils ont enlevaient les
enfants à l'âge de 2 ans il leur mettait
une kalachnikov dans les mains et puis
ensuite il les éduquait dans l'idée que
les parents avaient été tués par le
gouvernement colombien et et ça en
faisait des des enfants qui étaient qui
étaient perdus à jamais alors je ne dis
pas qu'ils sont perdus à jamais qu'on
comprenne bien encore une fois tout ça
est très très sensible mais je ne suis
pas persuadé qu'aujourd'hui on est
réfléchi à ce que l'on doit faire et
qu'on est les moyens de faire ce qu'il
faut faire pour les accueillir dans des
bonnes conditions écoutez le
gouvernement et la doctrine du
gouvernement il faut savoir qu'au moment
de la chute de daech en 2019 la France
et bien avait fait le choix de ne pas
rapatrier c'est ressortissants
prisonniers des camps syriens écoutez le
ministre de la Justice c'était cette
semaine au Sénat
nous n'avons pas changé la position du
gouvernement est extrêmement claire et
elle est précise ceux qui ont choisi
daesh doivent être jugés au plus près
des lieux où ils ont commis leur crime
mais mais ça n'est pas un petit mai il y
a des enfants madame la sénatrice oui
qui n'ont rien choisi et qui doivent
être traités avec humanité et vigilance
est-ce que le gouvernement a changé de
doctrine
on dirait qu'il a un petit peu accéléré
en fait cette politique du cas par cas
pour en effet
être conforme aux obligations légales
que le droit international nous demande
la CEDH mais aussi l'ONU donc moi je
crois qu'il y a un timing qui est
intéressant c'est à dire qu'à mon avis
ils ont quand même attendu la fin de la
campagne présidentielle parce qu'on voit
bien vu les réactions là à droite que
c'est pas un sujet facile que c'est un
sujet qui dans une campagne évidemment
avait propice à toutes les caricatures
et que en effet là je pense qu'il faut
être assez pragmatique en plus moi je
trouve que bombarde à retardement
l'expression un petit peu trop forte
parce que c'est on parle pas non plus de
dizaines de milliers de personnes on
parle de quelques dizaines quelques
centaines 300 enfants
dans l'Hexagone voilà donc en effet il
faut bien distinguer les enfants moi
j'ai l'impression que c'est plutôt bien
pris en charge de ce que je lis j'ai pas
encore été voir sur le terrain etc mais
j'ai l'impression que c'est quand même
un sort de triptyque entre des
éducateurs spécialisés la justice et les
psy et les hôpitaux qui sont très en
première ligne notamment dans les
Yvelines en Seine-Saint-Denis ce que je
trouve vraiment très bien et quand aux
femmes la plupart qui sont en prison bon
j'ai l'impression quand même qu'on les
surveille qu'on regarde après que la
prison soit un endroit pour qui augmente
la radicalisation on le sait
malheureusement depuis longtemps et je
crois qu'il faut maintenant penser la
pré prison aussi mais ça c'est pas c'est
un impensé des politiques pénal en
France la vraie bonbons à retardement
c'est tous les djihadistes même français
qu'on a enfermé suite à 2015 qui vont
bientôt sortir et est-ce qu'ils ont été
déradiquer en prison quand on lit les
témoignages en fait c'est loin loin
d'être le cas et ça ça va être un vrai
problème à gérer dans les années qui
viennent on va se détendre un peu les
amis pour nous bientôt acheter du
cannabis au coin de la rue c'est notre
dernier thème aujourd'hui si vous fumez
un joint en public vous êtes passif
d'une amende de 200 euros mais le 16e le
Conseil économique et social c'est
prononcer cette semaine en faveur d'une
légalisation encadrée et pour les
spécialistes aujourd'hui on a tout faux
écoutez évidemment lorsqu'on dit on est
pour la légalisation pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas le dossier ils sont de
moins en moins nombreux il faut le
reconnaître on a le sentiment d'être des
prosédé de la consommation c'est tout le
contraire la légalisation est une
démarche de réduction des risques qui a
pour mission de venir couper la course
folle de la consommation des drogues et
du cannabis en particulier en France
notamment chez les jeunes par une
politique pragmatique je vais vous lire
les recommandations du CESU le CESU qui
recommande la fin des sanctions contre
la consommation de cannabis la fin des
sanctions contre la culture de cannabis
à titre personnel ou encore la création
d'établissement spécialisée réservé aux
adultes des petits commerces quoi Michel
vous êtes tous exemple la légalisation
moi je dis pas de parole de Benoît Hamon
présidentielle c'était un des points de
notre de notre programme effectivement
donc je ne peux être que pour mais pas
par idéologie mais sur un constat c'est
l'échec total de toutes nos politiques
en matière de prévention de la drogue et
de drogue dans ce pays depuis des
décennies enfin je veux dire le nombre
de consommateurs on est un des plus
élevés d'Europe
il y a les banlieues pas que les
banlieues d'ailleurs vous trouvez
du cannabis à peu près partout il y
avait une interview de jeunes de jeunes
parisiens la sortie d'un lycée on leur
demandait est-ce que c'est difficile de
trouver du cannabis il est catégorie en
disant mais vous rigolez c'est plus
facile que d'aller acheter un paquet de
cigarettes au bureau de tabac d'à côté
donc on est dans une faillite totale
avec des problématiques sociales sociaux
sociales pardon énorme dans certains
quartiers on voit que des des noyaux
dealers moi ça donne ils peuvent pour ma
vie d'une cité entière voir parfois
d'une vie
sécher ce trafic assécher ce trafic et
il faut alors par contre le CESU ce que
je trouve de remarqua dans le rapport
que j'ai lu c'est que c'est pas on
s'occupe
etc et puis je vous dis l'argent qu'on
peut pas mettre aujourd'hui dans la
prévention puisque on ne peut pas
prévenir quand quelque chose qui
n'existe pas qui n'est pas légal on va
pouvoir aussi le mettre sur la table
pour là s'adresser aux plus jeunes mais
ne nous y trouvons pas hein c'est pas
que les plus jeunes qui fument
aujourd'hui si on fait le pourcentage
des des 30 50 ans je pense juste avant
de vous donner la parole en France près
de la moitié des adultes 46% ont déjà
consommé du cannabis contre un peu moins
d'un quart en moyenne dans l'ensemble de
l'Union européenne Eugénie moi je suis
partagée parce que je n'aime pas cet
argument parce que ça existe il faut
légaliser comme ça ce sera encadré parce
que à ce titre là on prend on pourrait
on pourrait aussi légaliser la
prostitution parce que on n'arrive pas à
lutter contre la précision elle existe
toujours pourquoi ne pas la légaliser
l'encadrer ce serait mieux moi je suis
contre donc je trouve que c'est un
argument parfois un peu fallacieux cela
dit c'est vrai que la prohibition pure
ne semble pas fonctionner je je suis
perplexe en fait sur ce sujet moi je
suis vraiment partagé et je pense que je
pense qu'en tout cas si il y a une
dépénalisation elle devra être
accompagnée d'une politique
intransigeante voire même radicale
envers les les filières clandestine et
délinquants et le trafic on continueront
à exister il y a deux choses il y a la
dépénalisation et puis la légalisation
la légalisation on va créer finalement
des petits commerces comme ça qui seront
encadrés et l'avance pas encadré par
l'État c'est pas exactement la même
chose
ça veut dire qu'on égalise aussi la
fabrication parce que si vous
dépanalisez ça en égalisez la
fabrication ça veut dire que vous
entretenez des filières clandestine ce
qui est absolument catastrophique
Emmanuel là dessus je suis d'accord il
faut soit légaliser soit interdire mais
dépénaliser non ça c'est la première
chose deuxième chose c'est que je pense
que c'est honnêtement le sens de
l'histoire toutes les grandes toutes les
grandes métropoles à travers le monde et
pas dans les dans des pays abandonnés
par la par la mondialisation l'ont
légalisée sont alors les pays qui ont
légalisé le cannabis récréatif on va
aller voir le Canada l'Uruguay quelques
États américains que vous connaissez
bien et puis en Europe Malte et
peut-être l'Allemagne d'ici 2024
maintenant maintenant il faut pas être
angélique non plus
la légalisation du cannabis
va pousser les filières clandestine à ce
réorienter vers d'autres vers d'autres
délits vers d'autres drogues et moi je
veux dire ma question c'est
comment est-ce qu'on fait si on si on
légalise le cannabis pour que ça
n'amplifie pas d'autres drogues dures
puisqu'il faudra trouver des moyens de
substitution pour ces pour ces dealers
pour ces petites bandes de quartiers qui
demain ne vendront plus du shit mais
vendront de la coupe de l'héroïne ou je
ne sais pas quoi c'est ça moi qui
m'inquiète le plus
il y a un proverbe qui dit chaque drogue
trouve son son
consommateurs et par exemple cette idée
comme ça on passerait du de du shit à la
cocaïne mais c'est deux effets c'est
deux effets psychotropes totalement à
l'opposé totalement différent
la personne qui cherche le consommateur
qui va chercher l'effet l'effet du gîte
s'il ne sait pas celui de la côte dont
je parle là où il y a une vraie problème
et dans les banlieues dans les banlieues
à côté de ces gamins-là on trouve aussi
ceux qui bossent chez
Hubert eats etc etc ils font de la
livraison donc il y a les deux dans ces
cas dans les mêmes endroits mais surtout
il faut il faut le dire un truc qu'on a
jamais dit qu'on dit pas assez souvent
l'année dernière il y a une il y a un
cartel qui est tombé en Italie le
jugement a eu lieu il y a quelques mois
ce cartel là était impliqué dans 80% du
trafic de shit et de de cannabis en
Europe
80% c'est un empire industriel leur
chiffre d'affaires dépassait celui de
certains États européens on a intégré on
a intégré ce que rapporte le trafic de
drogue au PIB français pour passer sous
les 3 %
il faut sortir ce truc là Astrid on a vu
que plusieurs pays effectivement ont
déjà légalisé c'est un débat voilà c'est
on disait on dirait on dit que c'est un
marronnier en langage journalistique
qu'est-ce qui bloque en France
je pense qu'il faut du courage pour
faire ça c'est à dire que c'est on
s'attaque quand même à quelque chose
d'énorme c'est à dire qu'il y a quand
même tout un système d'économie
parallèle qui fonctionne qui en effet
produit énormément de problèmes enfin
qui tient aussi certains quartiers donc
c'est si on fait ça on peut pas le faire
comme ça à l'improviste je pense que
heureusement qu'il y a eu le rapport du
CESU il y a aussi d'autres choses
intéressantes à noter par exemple la
ville de Reims tenue par Arnaud
robinetmer LR qui fait une
expérimentation dans sa ville je crois
que le débat vous dites ça marronnier
c'est vrai mais culturellement à période
régulière c'est quand même en train de
la ligne est quand même en train de
bouger c'est à dire que avant avant
c'était les écolos et Benoît Hamon voilà
de la gauche qui portait ça aujourd'hui
il y a eu un rapport à l'Assemblée
nationale il y a quelques années ou
transpartisans avec un député de gauche
un député à l'époque un art qui disait
en fait ceux qui bossent vraiment sur le
sujet les experts ils vous disent il
faut le faire après dans quelles
conditions comment comment on gère ces
quartiers là ensuite et puis moi je
trouve que la prévention en effet c'est
extrêmement important c'est on peut pas
non plus donner le message et c'est pas
du tout ce que fait ses œufs d'une
société c'est super le allez-y moi je
suis par exemple je suis totalement
opposé à ça donc il faut que ce soit
très très bien fait très très bien
encadré Eugénie là-dessus le mot de la
fin sur ce débat pourquoi on est à la
traîne en France je sais pas c'est alors
moi je crois pas là au sens de
l'histoire à la traîne la comparaison
parce que dans ce cas-là il faut faire
la réforme de traitement dans ce cas
enfin je si tous les il faut faire comme
tous les autres pays en faisant la
réforme des retraites donc je trouve
j'aime pas cet argument de benchmarking
on regarde ce que font les autres pays
on fait la même chose il faut réfléchir
sereinement et moi je suis ouverte au
débat je suis plutôt quelqu'un de à
droite et conservateur mais je trouve
qu'il faut être pragmatique et la
prohibition c'est vrai que ça ça a pas
marché pour l'alcool est-ce que le
est-ce que le cannabis c'est une est une
drogue qu'on peut considérer comme enfin
enfin il faut il faut évaluer les choses
je suis pas entièrement fermé même si je
pense qu'il faut être très prudent merci
président l'archet je vous donne la
parole dans deux secondes Emmanuel parce
que comme chaque semaine on va terminer
cette émission par un top flop je vous
pose à chacun une question très simple
quel personnalité a marqué l'actualité
en bien ou en mal Michel c'est à vous de
jouer votre top votre flop
consommer qui est plutôt je trouve une
pas si mauvaise nouvelle que ça c'est la
démission de Bernard Laporte de la
Fédération française de rugby vous savez
on parle souvent des valeurs de l'Ovalie
moi je j'étais vice capitaine du 15
parlementaire de rugby c'est un sport
dont je partage les valeurs et
auxquelles je crois voilà cette ça a été
sali il y a quelques à quelques mois de
la Coupe du monde de rugby ont peut-être
pouvoir enfin gagner dans ce pays je
pense c'est une bonne nouvelle qu'il
faut tourner la page de de l'air la
porte s'il y a vraiment vraiment mis à
mal
un très beau sport voilà et mon top
alors ça va être pour j'aurais pu
j'aurais pu parler de tous ceux qui vont
défier dans la rue pour lutter contre
les retraites parce que cela
mais ça serait pour
yassinda ardern l'ex première ministre
de néo-zélandaise qui a choisi notre vie
qui n'est pas accroché comme certains
politiques qui a démissionné qui avait
pourtant un plutôt intéressant si je
crois mais mes amis néo-zélandais
notamment sur la crise du covid donc ça
prouve que les parfois des politiciens
je pense aussi à pépé mujika qui était
le président
uruguayen des fois il y a des présidents
des des grands élus qui nous ressemblent
et qui ne sont pas tous pourris et tous
à mettre dans le même sac autrement à la
petite rumeur qui circulent il y a aussi
des gens de convictions
leur responsabilité voilà
mon top c'est Victor Castanet
journaliste indépendant qui a sorti les
fossoyeurs sur les EHPAD qui a mis au
jour la situation dramatique dans les
EHPAD de la façon dont on s'occupe de
nos aînés qui fait qui sortent ce
mercredi une réédition de son livre avec
plusieurs nouveaux chapitres sur les
pressions qu'il a pu et votre flop et
alors mon flop c'est Franck Riester
ministre des Relations avec le Parlement
qu'on entend très peu sauf pour nous
dire que la réforme finalement elle va
un peu pénaliser les femmes je pense
qu'il y avait pas plus gros plus grosses
bourde pour donner du grain à moudre aux
oppositions et contre son propre
gouvernement du temps François Hollande
on aurait parlé d'un quack
ski c'est plus un hommage parce que
voilà encore un homme qui a mis son art
au service de la juste cause pendant la
Seconde Guerre mondiale et et aussi une
autre une autre voie d'un témoignage
vivant qui s'éteint de cette période et
quand on sait tous les révisionnistes
qui nous guettent c'est voilà c'est
toujours triste dans voir un qui peut
témoigner en moins
le fleuve j'ai le droit de changer
la carte du club c'est gentil parce que
je voudrais pas dire la même chose que
ce que vous avez dit cher Michel sur sur
Bernard Laporte mon flop c'est Annie
d'algo parce que j'avais pas fait ma
petite trente ma petite séance Annie
d'algo à Lidl Go qui est maire de Paris
qui je vous le rappelle a été élu en
disant je serai pas candidate à élection
présidentielle j'augmenterai pas les
impôts avec le succès qu'on connaît et
qui là alors que en tant que maire de
Paris devrait être la garante de la
continuité du service public appelle sa
mairie a fermé les portes c'est un
scandale absolument
génial votre flops
c'est le rapport aux femmes sur les
inégalités qui appellent à supprimer les
milliardaires parce que chaque
milliardaire je cite est un échec
politique je trouve c'est complètement
stupide de penser quand parce qu'il y
aurait moins de milliardaires il y
aurait moins de pauvres c'est une un des
vases communicants et c'est vraiment ça
participe à cette ambiance populiste de
solutions simpliste votre autre flop une
autre flop c'est l'agence de presse
américaine AP qui qui a fait un
communiqué pour pour des conseils des
plus gros agences de presse pour pour
des conseils d'écriture à ces
journalistes qui dit d'éviter les
étiquettes globales il faut pas écrire
par exemple les pauvres les handicapés
et pas les Français parce que c'est trop
stigmatisant troglob trop généraliste
voilà le délire du politiquement correct
poussait jusqu'au bout merci à tous les
quatre c'est la fin de cette émission
merci à vous derrière votre écran la
personne qui est dans l'oreillette me
dit que vous êtes de plus en plus
nombreux à nous regarder et à nous
revoir en replay et en podcast merci à
vous on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
même jour même heure et même endroit bye
bye
[Musique]